All right. So, you have learned your
first few poi tricks and now you have
run across a little bit of a problem. As
you're doing your three beat weaves or
perhaps you're doing your butterflies,
maybe you're even doing your windmills.
How exactly do you get back and forth
between all these different po tricks?
They seem like just kind of isolated
islands of ideas. So, how do you
actually connect the dots together and
make them flow together? Well, the name
of the game is transitions. And in this
video, I'm going to take you through
several different concepts for
transitions that are specifically geared
towards
beginners. Drex here from Drex Factor
PO, sharing with you the love of PO
spinning and flow arts to benefit your
body and brain. And in this video, I am
breaking down some of my best tips for
transitions for you beginners out there.
But before we dive in, I just want to
give a quick shout out to the friends of
the channel. Big thanks to Dark Monk,
Fire Mecca, Flowfests, Flow Toys, Parot
Light Toys, and Ultraoy for helping to
make the videos on this channel
possible. You can learn more about all
these awesome companies and the work
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
down in the description of this video.
And special thanks to the non-b
businessiness friend of the channel,
Pekka Becklanin. Thank you so very much
for supporting my channel, my work, and
my mission. All right, so we're gonna
start this off with a little bit of an
old man yells a cloud moment here, and
that is that I have come to believe that
we just don't teach poi, right? Like we
have these nice little discrete pieces
of repeatable movement that we refer to
as tricks that totally make people feel
like they've made an accomplishment when
they get them down. And as well they
should. They become these little things
that we can look to as a benchmark of,
hey, I got something down in my flow
journey here. The problem is though is
that when we create these really
discreet little islands of movement, we
also come up with a system that kind of
discourages people from hopping back and
forth between them. We don't really
integrate all these tricks together in
our learning. And that is part of why
transitions wind up being such a
challenge for beginners. So, I'm going
to do my best to start bridging the gaps
to make it seem as though those bridges
are not vast gulfs in empty space, but
actually just clear little rivers that
take us from place to place quite
easily. All right, so the first thing I
want to cover here is something that
most beginners never think of, but that
can actually yield a surprising amount
of per when it comes to switching back
and forth between things. And it doesn't
require you to change the direction of
the po. It doesn't require you to add or
subtract beats or anything like that
that we're going to get into later on in
this list. But what it does require you
to do is change the size of the trick.
Let me show you what I mean. So, here's
how this actually works in practice.
Now, this is me spending split time same
direction at my waist. And we would
refer to this as being a watermill. But
the moment I open it up and perform that
same motion with my full arms, all of a
sudden, I've worked my way up to
something that we would refer to as a
giant. Likewise, if I'm playing around
with a butterfly inside of a small area
and then I go big, it looks as though
I've switched into a different trick,
even though the mechanics of the trick
are exactly the same. There are other
variations on this that don't produce as
dramatic results. Like say if we go from
a small space doing a three beat weave
to opening up our arms each time we do
it. We still kind of think of this as
looking like a three beat weave, but it
has a very, very different and very
dramatic presentation to it. So, it can
be helpful to play around anytime you
pick up a new trick with playing around
with what happens when you open up and
then decrease the volume of it. And you
might in the process discover that you
have access to a brand new trick.
Awesome. All right. So, for our second
transition concept, I am going to lean
heavily on something that I think is the
most slept on transition option in the
PO world, and that is pendulums. Now, a
lot of transitions rely on us switching
the direction of at least one PO, if not
both. And we have a few different
options of how to do it. But for my
money, the pendulum is the one that we
ought to be teaching beginners, and we
seldom do. The reason for this is it
doesn't require a lot of training to be
able to do a pendulum. You pretty much
just have to let the poi hang and go
back and forth. but also too, it
accomplishes that goal of switching the
PO's direction without any fuss. And it
teaches you some important information
about how to change the momentum of the
PO on the fly. So, to show you just how
powerful a tool this is, I'm going to
use pendulums to get back and forth
between a bunch of different tricks here
while my left-hand po keeps spinning.
So, to start off with, I can get myself
into a butterfly here. And with a little
wave of my magic wand, I can get into
spinning the poi in together. Same and
get to my reels. Now with another
pendulum, I'm back to a butterfly based
trick. In this case, a thread the
needle. And I can then get into a
threebeat weave like so. Or I can switch
back into that butterfly before getting
into something more dramatic like say a
windmill or pruvian man. In each of
these cases, I'm just using that
pendulum as a way to move back and forth
between these different tricks,
different timing and direction modes.
From there, I can just enter into the
trick at will. This is an incredibly
powerful tool to have at your disposal.
So, don't be afraid to play around with
it. Get really good at performing
pendulums with at least one hand, and
all of a sudden, so many options will
open up to you. All right. So, for our
third transition technique here, I'm
going to have you work with something
that I'll be honest with you, a lot of
beginners struggle with, and that is
controlling the number of beats that
they perform with the poi as they're
spinning them. So, this is actually
going to hearken back to something that
I remember as being the first transition
with poi that I ever learned, which was
when I got down my waist straps within
my first year of spinning. I remember
learning how to take those waist straps
up and around my head into a windmill
and then back down into waist straps. I
remember this as being a really, really
crucial moment when I was able to get
two different PO tricks to stick
together like Lego blocks. And the funny
thing is is now we actually think of
this as being so common that we call it
a trick in and of itself. We call this a
four beat or a 4x4 fountain. And there's
nothing wrong with that. But we can
extend the knowledge that I gained in
that into a little exercise. So we can
add and subtract beats to what really
amounts to just taking our hands around
our bodies in a circle here. So I'm
going to start it off with a windmill,
which is a two beat move. I'm performing
a beat around my ears and a beat down in
front of me here. And then I'm going to
add that bottom waist part to turn it
into a four beat fountain. And now I'm
performing four beats. And now I'm going
to transform the top part of it into the
top part of a waist strap or fountain
and bring the total number of beats to
six. So I have six beats and then I have
four beats and then I have two beats.
Four
beats, six
beats, four beats, and then two beats.
And all I'm doing is making choices
about where I am adding and subtracting
these pieces from. In point of fact, I
could just go straight back and forth
between my windmill and that full
fountain, the six beat version, if I
wanted to. I don't have to stop in the
four beat fountain. But doing so is a
great lesson in how I can add different
beats at different spots around my body
and change the character of what the
audience sees. This is also the
principle at work when you switch back
and forth between, say, extensions and
flowers. You add extra beats with the
poi and it looks like a different move.
And it should be said, it kind of
changes the tempo of the move as well.
There are plenty of other examples as
well. So, I highly encourage you to
explore this realm as well. Add and
subtract beats from the things that
you're learning how to do, and you may
just discover that you've discovered a
new transition between two things you
already know how to do. All right, so
for our last transition option, we are
once again going to look at direction
changes. And specifically, we've already
looked at pendulums here, but the most
popular option for direction changes is
certainly stalls. So, all those things
that we played around with in learning
our pendulums, we should also take a
look at through the lens of stalls as
well. Now, me personally, I think that
it's better to teach people pendulums
first if for no other reason than the
physics of them are so much easier on
the body. Takes people a little bit of
work to learn how to do really clean
stalls. But once they do have their
stalls down, we want to really perform
the same operations with our stalls that
we did with our pendulums. So we want to
play around in a together opposites
place. Perform a stall and have that
take us into our reels. Another stall
takes us back to our
butterflies. And we use another stall to
get into our windmills, back to our
butterflies, and of course into our
weaves. We want to use these stalls not
only as transition tools, but also if
you'll notice, we can treat them kind of
as a percussive moment rather than the
kind of gooey squishy feel that the
pendulums have. A stall feels a lot more
like a point, a moment where boom, we
can almost hear the crack of a drum
underneath it. We can use these as
points where we can really draw out
emphasis in a moment. And especially if
we do our downstalls, we can kind of let
that moment sizzle before we move on.
They're very useful in that regard.
Above all, the biggest thing I want to
emphasize in this is that we should
treat drilling transitions as being as
important as learning tricks in and of
themselves. Otherwise, we wind up with a
pile of those tricks, but no way to put
them together. And that's not fun either
for us or for our audiences. And if you
like these ideas but would like more
detailed exercises on how you can work
on them in practice, then you're in luck
because that is the theme of the flow
circle for the month of June. The flow
circle is a weekly exclusive lesson
that's available only to my Patreon
supporters. And the theme for June is
all about transitions and specifically
transitions exercises for beginners.
We'll take a deeper look at a lot of the
different ideas that I put out in this
video. And even better, I will give you
specific drills that you can do to get
these skills down. Go sign up at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo. The first
lesson is available now. What are your
favorite transition tools for beginners?
Did I miss one? Leave me a comment and
let me know what it was. Also, be sure
to like, share, and subscribe to help
other people find this video and of
course to help my channel grow.
This video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a shout out
to my FL patrons who are listed on
screen right now. Thank you all so much.
You rock. And if you are interested in
getting your name in the credits or
access to a host of any other of the
rewards that I have posted, you can go
sign up for my Patreon over at
patreon.com/drexfactor po. I'll include
a link to it down in the description as
well as up in the cards. Thank you in
advance. And if you want a super
detailed version of that pendulum drill
that I was discussing earlier in this
video, uh I actually did an entire video
just on that drill alone, which uh I
think looks pretty cool and also is
going to help you out in feeling more
comfortable with your transitions in
general. So, I will link to that down in
the description as well as up on screen.
Thank you so much for watching. Make
sure to get out and flow today
yourselves and I'll see you with a new
video real soon. Take care. Peace.